la inflación ha sido endémica en Turquía
durante la última década espoleada por
la poco ortodoxa política económica de
recepta y perdugante con los precios de
los alimentos triplicándose en el último
año los ciudadanos turcos luchan por
cubrir sus necesidades básicas que
podemos comprar la carne picada cuesta
330 libras el kilo y la carne aún más el
gobierno dice que hay que comprar
Cordero pero creen que podemos comprar
cordero con nuestras pensiones las
empresas se hunden ante los elevados
gastos generales
he sido propietario de una pequeña
empresa durante mucho tiempo y por
primera vez he llegado al límite de mis
tarjetas de crédito pedimos préstamos
para pagar las deudas y no es suficiente
nuestros ingresos no cubren en absoluto
nuestros gastos
tras gobernar Turquía durante una década
de éxitos económicos con una industria
floreciente y un crecimiento constante
la marea económica cambió
esperaba mantener esta prosperidad con
bajos tipos de interés y prestamos más
accesibles forzando al Banco Central a
alinearse con su política esto ha hecho
bajar el valor de la lira que ha caído
un 80% frente al dólar en los últimos
cinco años por si fuera poco el
terremoto de febrero causó daños
estimados en 103 mil millones de dólares
la decisión de erdogan fue crear un
fondo de reconstrucción y la Unión
Europea ofreció 7000 millones en total
pero las promesas hasta ahora distan
mucho de lo que se necesita